I just have to say that you're amazing I came in
and I felt very sort of like I've been doing a
lot of press and I was sort of in like press
mode and kind of like saying the thing and
then just you sharing that thank you for sharing
and I felt like just an immediate connection and
like the Press walls kind of dropped and then
I was like just like a human moment so much
I was voracious and went after you like a crazy
person wanting to have a conversation with you
because of the things I went through in my life
and with my mom and growing up in this industry
first of all this cover I
love you so much the humor
how did you get to the humor of this did you earn
it have you always had a sense of humor well with
the title specifically I always knew that I wanted
it to be called I'm glad my mom died I wanted
something that would be really bold and attention
grabbing and hopefully that people with a sense
of humor would get you know and also I think
anybody with who's experienced parental abuse
understands and I I didn't feel so concerned with
I knew there would be you know some people who are
like I don't get that title but I thought that'd
be that'd be totally fine and when people maybe
don't get the the comedy and the tone yeah how
do they behave and what how does it make you feel
um I try to stay off like Twitter but
every interview that I've done so far
the the interviewer has been sure to let
me know hey that title is very divisive
um and I think that anything worth saying is
probably going to be divisive I think if it's
not divisive it's probably there's probably no
new conversation to be had there so I felt it
was an important and worthwhile title does someone
have to die in order to be able for us to tell our
truth I think we at least have to write as if
they have died which is that old saying right
like right as if everyone you know is dead um
I've never heard that one before I don't know
who said it but I'm pretty sure it's it's like
a I I think it's a saying I don't think I just
coined it I know I've never heard it before I've
definitely heard like right as if no one's reading
it or dances if nobody's watching I mean by the
way that's the new mug being sold dog shelves I'm
actually asking honestly yeah like do I have to
wait to tell on my truths I don't know if I can do
it because certain people are alive I understand
my thought on that is I think if saying the truth
ends a relationship I think it's probably a
relationship that needed to end I guess does
that make sense like yeah it does it probably
there was probably some painful uncomfortable
truth that was just needing to be expressed for
a long time and if saying that out loud is going
to end the relationship I think it's probably
better off not being in a person's life how do
you get over guilt and shame if they're still
alive in order to tell those truths oh my God
guilt and shame are tough I really I I
struggle to navigate guilt and shame for
a long time I would get them confused but I was
told by a therapist that I loved that guilt can
sometimes be worthwhile because it can say oh
maybe there's a correction to be made in like
a life path or a lifestyle choice but that shame
is not really worthwhile that it kind of keeps you
stuck and can like Spiral that was really helpful
to understand I think the nuances between the two
so I would say the shame the shame is is is I just
don't think it's a a valuable emotion really but
I do think with guilt do you think it's warranted
guilt do you think it's unwarranted I think when
it comes to our moms we want so badly to have
this relationship that I can't even say society
says we're supposed to have it is nature it is
nurture it's Evolution when you met your therapist
is it true that you were like my mom's great
things are good everything's awesome I just
have to say that you're amazing I came in and
I felt very sort of like I've been doing a lot
of press and I was sort of in like press mode
and kind of like saying the thing and then just
you sharing that thank you for sharing and
I felt like just an immediate connection and
like the Press walls kind of dropped and
then I was like just like a human moment
much here to ask advice I I relate to your
journey so much I feel like I have a lot to
learn from you oh man I really do I'm so glad
you said that because I don't think of this
as the same thing I I wanted I just was like
can I please talk with her I one human being
to another yes that feeling is just yeah wow
and also I knew I could trust you because you
did have comedy in there when it's all so dark
and heavy I'm like I don't want anything to do
with you if you haven't found comedy as a coping
mechanism we have nothing to talk about So when
you say that I feel like I can't take somebody
seriously if they're too serious because I'm
like they don't where's the humor like there are
Shades to reality it's never just dramatic it's
never just funny it's always layered and messy
and gunky and that's juicy you know I couldn't
agree more because as actors you're like
put it all out there you think you're so out
there but like that dark stuff that's in there
right it's real deep and buried yes so how did
you start your therapy journey and how did
you start to unpack well initially when I
when I went to therapy I did have my mom still
on the pedestal and every time I felt defensive
immediately when my first therapist Laura started
asking questions about my mom immediately I went
into well she did this but it's because she's
such a good mom it's because she wanted me to
be successful it's because she wanted me to have a
better like everything had a I I was so defensive
I didn't realize that I was at the time but in
retrospect I see oh I was disclaiming every single
thing that my mom did instead of just stating the
reality or how I felt about it it was I was more
concerned with how I how to keep my mom looking
good than I was with expressing my true emotional
reality okay I think I'm having an aha moment
Tell Me Maybe it's protectiveness that I feel
I've never put it in those terms in my head wow
I got bills it's like I don't want to paint her
negatively I don't want people to think of her
negatively yes but the truth is tough stuff
yeah I it took me a long
time to accept that my mom
was not perfect let alone abusive like it went in
baby steps to to put these pieces of the puzzle
together and to recognize the reality of the
pain that I'd suppressed for decades at that
point you know I first went to there when I was
20 22 or 23. wow what did your therapist do that
made you feel like you could keep going because I
think it's interesting because at many different
therapy approaches many different styles people
who are out there maybe wanting to open up to
therapy what's a red flag what's a green flag
what was it for you interestingly I'm only now
piecing this together but so I left my first
I talked about this aspect in the book but I
left my first therapist when she suggested I was
telling her kind of stories of my relationship
with my mom she said hey what you're expressing
is is abuse are you aware of that I broke down
I quit therapy that night and it takes you want
to run away oh yeah maybe it was too harsh too
fast yes like I started with eating disorder
with an eating disorder specialist so it was
very clinical very checklist pen and paper and
we didn't get into trauma or childhood stuff we
didn't get into any of that and I think I needed
that at the time because I I think I needed to
get that addiction uh under control before being
able to go anywhere near like Excavating the stuff
from the past I think that was to it would
have been too I think that would have fueled
the addiction if I were working on that in tandem
with the addiction so you had positive experiences
breaking down one of the aspects of what you
needed to work on and your eating disorder has
a history oh yeah I mean your mom talked about
calorie control when you were young 11 yeah
it I mean the way your mom spoke to you it it
obviously is so unacceptable that we find as
adults now who know better but how do you know
what's okay and not okay when you're a kid um I
I feel like the thing is when like when you're
a kid you don't know that you're in a traumatic
situation or that you're in a not normal situation
because it's just your reality you have nothing to
really compare it to it's just so your own your
own experience so I had no idea that I was in a
traumatic environment to me that's where some of
the comedy actually comes from is because it's
like that denial innocent child point of view so
my mom would be chasing my dad around the house
of the kitchen knife and I'd be like rooting her
on I'd be like oh mom like you got this and it's
like that's messed up but when I was six I didn't
know that was messed up my dad used to come in and
break he used to come in our house and break
everything and my mom and I would come home to
like the entire house like just ransacked and
it you know I was like well I could I know this
weirdly I was so rational with my dad I don't
know how he got a free pass I was like you're
an incapable person you are totally screwed up
talk to me about what happened with your dad
so after I guess this was maybe a year and a
half after my mom died my who I thought was
my father told me that he was not actually my
biological father what was your first reaction
um I remember feeling like I got the wind knocked
out of me my mouth was really dry uh and I
I think I hugged him and then um his then
girlfriend sort of like joined the hug and
she was well-meaning but I was like okay this
is just a hug between us too we don't need
another Embrace on top of it yeah I feel like that
always happens when there are two people hugging
and there's like a third person standing in the
room who feels left out they're like I guess I
should join and I start joining we're like
oh this is excessive God I think sometimes I
have been that third person hugging probably more
often than not I'm like really that's a license to
hug all right let's bring it in It's probably
hard to know how to react did you did you say
okay this person's not my biological father
but he's been there as a father I didn't feel
that way I felt that he had always been
pretty disengaged and disconnected so
um it was shocking but I I also started to
find excuses for him in that information
meaning oh well that's why he was so absent all
those years not really realizing well that that
wasn't oh also you know what he said to me
he said it's not your fault you were born he
repeat and then he repeated it he like doubled
down and then tripled down and I thought like
this is the weirdest thing to say to somebody
after you've just told them that you're not
their biological father what did he mean by that
I I don't know he I don't know I really have you
ever asked him no I just didn't I sort of just
that was that was a relationship that I kind of
let dissolve let disintegrate it wasn't there
wasn't really much there to begin with and so
you were like here is my green light to not
have shame or guilt and move on initially I
felt a lot of guilt and tried to really work
on that relationship and and and you know see
him and and his then I guess maybe she became
his wife shortly after that um I tried to see
them quite often and then it just didn't feel
right in my bones I just felt like this is
that I what we're talking about there's no
real connection here it just doesn't feel
um it just doesn't feel right in my bones and
and so then I just so time allowed you to start
to disengage yes yes what about your biological
father I I went to meet him and um we had a really
great kind of first conversation and then we saw
each other for maybe three to four months once a
week probably for that amount of time and then
it got to a place where that one felt a little
a little strange also my brothers two I have three
older brothers two of them are all Brothers follow
your biological Brothers yeah and they hadn't
met him and I was sort of doing the thing of
like trying to get them to meet him and thinking
like oh this could be good this could be healing
for all of us and we're gonna build that
family uh exactly oh my God that was my goal
from oh my God being a little girl was I want
a good family I want a good family I I really
understand that wanting to create the nuclear
family like you you will make it work you know
you you and I found my friends you know now I
have two kids and a huge family and when their
dad and I didn't work out that was I that took
me down like that was it I was like this was the
almighty plan I didn't know if I would even ever
have children because of my relationship with my
mom and then when I did and it didn't work out
it I I I didn't think I could experience more
trauma failure wow and emotions than when that
happened I was like oh this is the big one I
thought that happened when you were 13 or blah
blah blah okay we can always be surprised that
the nervous breakdown's gonna happen it 40 and not
13 in a mental institution what a revelation okay
I but I I we are we're now doing great you
can make it till you make it good but those
kids first were like a model of co-parenting
I really mean it like I'm so glad we got there
we're survivors you get there you make it but do
you ever do you want children do you think about
having children do you have a vision of what that
is are you like what what is your feelings about
that I don't think I want children I'm open to my
mind changing on it like it so far hasn't
seemed appealing to me um but I wonder why
oh my God I know as soon as I found
out I was having a girl I was like oh
here we go let's get on that karmic wheel and
fix this and then I found out I was having a
second daughter and everything changed really
I was like oh um ah you're gonna raise girls
that's your purpose here on this planet wow and
it changed everything oh my God yeah oh that's
so nice to hear oh my God it was a real relief I
I know this I know I don't want to have kids from
um like to to get an identity you know I feel
like I'm lucky there because I've done a lot
of work on my identity and myself and feel
clear um as clear as possible I think at 4
30 and I know that will continue to evolve
and change and I expect that um but I also
wouldn't want to have kids out of any sort of
boredom or to save a relationship those are
kind of the three things where I feel like oh if
I don't do those I think I'm off to a good start
you are so healthy
I mean really you are just so healthy this
journey of self-awareness methodologies
opinions insights into life are so profound
and they're paying off so much I have to
say I think you'll be an amazing parent if
you choose to be one thank you I really do
you think just have your head on so straight
and you're so clear on everything and I think
us who didn't have a certain type of love maybe
even have more of it to give as a last question
if I may who are you now oh that's a that's a
giant last question that's huge that's really big
who am I now you know I feel it the simplest
answer I guess is that I feel like myself I feel
like I lived so long being sort of who I thought
I needed to be for different situations and
um and I feel like I never could have sat down
here and just talked to you as me like it's so
powerful to be able to to feel like I can be
authentic and feel like I can be me and my skin
and not have to run from that and pretend to be
somebody that I just don't that I know deep inside
is not me like that's I I do think kind of so many
people relate to that specific Journey whether
or not they're in the entertainment industry
or acting or what have you I think that that
journey of authenticity that's the corniest way
of phrasing it that it can possibly be afraid oh
it's true it's a like even if you tell your truth
you'll be okay yeah yeah I think just I think just
yeah being being authentic there's such a a nice
feeling to it that's like can't be taken away or
um compromised and that feels really it feels like
legitimate strength not like over compensatory
strength ooh big word I get a point I love big
words I am so happy to meet you you too it's
so helpful and healing thank you so much for
everything that you're putting out there and
I just uh I love you I'm glad my mom died is
available now everybody knows about it because
it's a best seller and it's being downloaded
and breaking records and that's what the truth
can do thank you Jeanette thank you so much for
having me this has been like so amazing oh my God